-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
And now if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
Today is Halloween,
so if you like jump scares,
ghouls, and goblins,
then you just have to wait
eight more days.
[ Light laughter ]
Until that.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden early voted
over the weekend in Delaware
because people his age
do everything early.
Voting two weeks before
the election, dinner at 4:30.
Hell, his luggage is already
packed for Christmas vacation.
[ Light laughter ]
That's right.
President Biden voted
over the weekend,
and in the interest
of bipartisanship,
he voted for everyone.
[ Laughter ]
"I like them all.
They're all good fellas."
[ Light laughter ]
Tesla's CEO Elon Musk last week
completed the $44 billion deal
to take control of Twitter.
And meanwhile, a lot
of his customers are still
trying to take control
of their Teslas.
[ Laughter ]
After completing the purchase of
Twitter on Thursday,
Elon Musk sent a tweet directed
at the social media company's
advertisers
and said the platform
"obviously cannot become
a free-for-all hellscape."
No, but it could stay that.
[ Laughter ]
During last week's
Pennsylvania Senate debate,
Republican candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz said
that he thought the decisions
about abortion
should be left up to
"women, doctors,
local political leaders."
Though to be fair,
in some cases,
that local political leader
may be the father.
[ Laughter ]
Just statistically...
President Biden is reportedly
considering a plan to
use Guantanamo Bay
to house Haitian migrants.
Unfortunately
he's going to have to wait
another few days
to move them in.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, yesterday was
National Candy Corn Day,
which makes today national
"there's still plenty
of candy corn day."
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.